welcome to this video playing not lazon
from from from from Denmark right yep
and we have an English opening probably
they are here what has this be formals
the Makino so check it's a quite quite
an interesting way to play 97's somewhat
unusual usually they go deform but let's
see
I'm not sure if I really really played
in the best possible best possible
manner but it looks it looks decent I'm
winning this spawn at the moment okay
what is this idea probably taking only
five okay all this doesn't look too bad
if it takes on e5 there c5 hanging so so
95 95 95 25 rupees only only a line that
is red requires some help
my white
yeah it's got some problems now if he
plays some Queenie 7 for instance I have
firm probably just Bishop g5 winning get
another tempo now maybe Queenie 8 but I
just played Bishop f4 heads it's really
it's really just not great came
protective 5
yeah that looks like a very nice
position okay should I am just castle
now
Romney Queen takes Knight Texas ugly
fine it's a it's nice to have this
before but this doesn't necessarily mean
I'm winning easily because he's got some
good pieces yeah this nights for
instance are quite are quite okay I mean
they have good posts still its opponent
yeah I don't know should I lose it
tonight or not yeah probably I should
move it d6 is not exactly a bad square
but it also protects the d4 square yeah
yeah this is better than possibly
allowing him to take it
nozzles should be quite okay
and if he goes work the ada play 96 hmm
but this is a bit of a self pain right
now come on I can just do that I'm
thinking f1 then with the other one
really was a self pin I can I think I'm
better off doing this with a quick
kingly - interesting
probably a good idea to flick this in
anyway
so king e to rock t5 probably 96
you know he's got the Streif or idea
there's some better better way to play
hmm I don't I don't like that too much
kingi Joe probably I shouldn't I should
play this first King it to us various
problems attached to it 94 with check
and this kind of stuff here I'm not even
sure how he protects g4 maybe rock rock
t2 just active defense attacking be too
I can also increase the pressure on this
poem with 98 f6 Knight f5 h6 kind of
stuff I don't really see a move now man
that that really helps them
you know something active him okay let's
grab it
give this chick I can just take it I can
just take it it took me a while to see
that sometimes you're just thinking far
too complicated can just take take the
night black resigned young well hard to
say somehow he never really got out of
the opening and it seemed I don't know
maybe here you should you should do
something else I mean I expected Queen
b6 really counter-attacking on if to my
attention was to play Bishop c4 but I'm
not I'm not entirely sure what what this
is one one interesting move now is
Knight a form no idea
I hadn't really calculated this in much
detail I was only thinking that after
Queen b6 it is very lame to try to
defend to the phone computer our
computer was to go six yeah this is of
course also a move tactical move yeah
very unclear I mean this is probably
what he should do and ya know I don't
really know if he's still able to get
out of this I mean he he in this
position I don't think like is in such
terrible shape but somehow it it got
worse really quickly probably probably
Bishop a fighters bad the night really
wants to go to d6 you know ninety six is
of course an alternative I didn't what I
didn't like is that now the knight is in
a bit of a self pinned I cannot I don't
really threaten to take
this is why I took and played King
everyone try to a victor look this yeah
this is probably okay for for a wide
this seems to be a mistake yeah he
cannot really protect this now I can try
rock before when I can if everything
else fails I'll take p7 just take all
pawns and this is probably lost it took
me awhile to recognize it was was saying
though you know it's in the opening this
is important if you have this position
as black and e5d for the much better the
much better way to play and much easier
as well why it would take take and then
after this let's say something like this
black IAM at the end gets gets his
pieces out and it's close to equality
okay thanks for watching